Israel is not only Waging War on Gaza
it's also increasing the frequency and
intensity of its incursions in the
occupied West Bank as Imran mentioned
the Palestinian prisoners society says
Israeli forces and settlers have killed
at least 314 Palestinians since October
the 7th about one in every four was a
child one was a woman and six were
prisoners who died in Israeli custody
more than 3,800 Palestinians have been
injured in the occupied West Bank in the
past 3 months most during Israeli raids
but some in attacks by settlers an
increase in raids means an increase in
arrests more than 4,800 Palestinians
have been detained and of those 261 are
miners in other words younger than 18
and 48 are
journalists in total the prisoners
organization says
7,820 Palestinians are currently
detained in Israeli jails and looking at
the whole year is forces and settlers
have killed
522 Palestinians 118 of them children
making 2023 the most dangerous on record
for Palestinians living in the occupied
West Bank according to the
UN Mustafa alui is Secretary General of
the Palestinian national initiative and
a former information Minister he joins
us now from rala uh Mr bouti good to
have you with us on the program you have
been in rala obviously all this time
before I ask you sort of the in depth of
conversation we want to have about
what's been happening overnight in your
region what what inclination did you
have that there was a problem early in
the early hours of this
morning well uh this morning they
invaded ramala not only I mean one
neighborhood they invaded several
neighborhoods in ramala as they did in
he and and in and J practic ially what
is happening is that Israel is
reoccupying the West Bank completely
they are marginalizing the Palestinian
Authority the depriving it from all its
authorities there is no security control
of the Palestinian Authority because the
Israeli Army invades all cities all area
a That was supposed to be under
Palestinian Authority the Israeli Army
was also taking away from them their
legal situation I mean if they invade
the money changing places that are
licensed by the Palestinian Authority
and then confiscate their money this is
a serious violation this is a message
clear from Netanyahu clear message from
Netanyahu is's saying there is no place
anymore for any independent Palestinian
Authority here he's reoccupying West
Bank as he is trying to reoccupy Gaza
are you concerned that is a very
negative message are you concerned
there's going to be a backlash because
analysts that we've been speaking to uh
throughout the last few weeks when
talking about the West Bank is is Isel
is trying to come down on the West Bank
heavily so that a second front a second
violent front is not opened up against
the
Israelis well as you said no this is not
the the case actually Netanyahu is
trying to provoke a second front not to
suppress a second front when he arrests
when he kills more than 522 people in
the West Bank when he kill since the 7th
of October 314 of those 66 are children
and women additionally and civilian all
of them are civilians and when he
arrests more than almost 5,000 new
Palestinians and puts them in very
difficult conditions he is trying and
Netanyahu didn't hide that he spoke
about that verbally and clearly he said
he wants to open another front in the
West Bank so no the goal of the Israeli
security measures in the West Bank is
not really to suppress the possibility
of an in but to provoke an in because
this man Netanyahu knows very well that
if he leaves his position as prime
minister he will go to jail this man
wants to extend the war in Gaza to
expand it to continue it as long as
possible he wants to open the northern
front as well and he wants a third front
in the West Bank because his survival
depends on the continuation of this
terrible War if that is the case Mr
barouti then where is the Palestinian
Authority and where is the the where are
the raised voices of the Palestinian
Authority including its president Mahmud
Abbas I think the position of the
authority should go in One Direction
unifying Palestinians and what we need
now is more more than any time before a
unified Palestinian national leadership
and a unified Palestinian interim
government giving the people eventually
the right to choose their leaders
through free Democratic elections but at
this very moment what we Face here is a
much bigger challenge than even the
catastrophe that happened in 1948 and
that requires that we are all Unified
and United in confronting this our
people in Gaza are facing terrible
terrible situation they're facing
starvation they're having epidemics that
are affecting almost 400,000 people now
uh 75% of their homes were completely
destroyed and Israel continues to try to
ethnically cleanse them if it wasn't for
the strong American strong Egyptian
position against ethnic cleansing and it
wasn't for the people who are determined
to stay on their land Israel would have
conducted ethnic cleansing in Gaza and
they would have gone further in trying
to conduct ethnic cleansing in the West
Bank as well so this is the clear
picture Netanyahu wants more Wars
because his real goal is ethnic
cleansing and he has failed in in
achieving that but what we need now is
Palestinian national unity in front of
these terrible dangers if that's the
case if you're saying you want
Palestinian national Unity you see a
strong Egypt standing up uh to Israel
which way now in terms of stopping the
fighting at least getting a ceasefire in
place do we look to the diplomats or do
we look to Civil Society I mean dare I
say Civil Society in the sense that if
you have more fighting on the
Palestinian side it's only going to
allow the Israelis to come down hard
especially in the West Bank even more
than they are
already look the Civil Society is trying
its best to alleviate the suffering of
the Palestinian people we are working
very hard at The Intern level to expose
the Israeli crimes but at the end of the
day it is the United States of America
which has the responsibility now of
restraining Israel of restraining
Netanyahu of telling Israel enough is
enough you cannot proceed with these
terrible three war crimes genocide
ethnic cleansing and Collective
punishment this this has to stop and the
only country that can stop them is the
United States of America which has not
only been complexit with these crimes
Unfortunately they have been
participating in them and that's why
they have a responsibility and what we
need immediately is ceasefire permanent
continuous ceasefire to stop the
atrocities to stop the killing of the
people and then initiate negotiations
about exchange of prisoners and maybe
then start a true real uh political
process to achieve the goal the main
goal the cause of all problems which is
ending the Israeli occupation of
Palestinian land Musta baruti from the
Palestinian national initiative thanks
so much your time
sir thank you